democracia ya Esas son las palabras
escritas en los carteles que portaban
los jóvenes israelíes en las calles de
tel aviv el sábado ondeando banderas
arcoíris y portando antorchas miles de
manifestantes marcharon contra el nuevo
gobierno del Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu considerado uno de los más
derechistas de la historia del país
[Música]
He venido a protestar para defender mi
futuro como israelí como judía que
quiere vivir en un país democrático y
seguro
estoy segura de que estas
manifestaciones crecerán y crecerán y
crecerán y al final echaremos a este
gobierno
asumió el cargo del mes pasado tras
ganar las elecciones en noviembre el
Primer Ministro de 73 años que está
luchando en los tribunales contra
acusaciones de corrupción es el que más
tiempo lleva en el cargo ahora encabeza
una coalición con partidos judíos de
extrema derecha y Ultra ortodoxos luego
gobierno ha anunciado políticas
preocupantes que incluyen la expansión
de los asentamientos en cisjordania
ocupada la introducción de un programa
que permite el parlamento anular las
decisiones del tribunal supremo y
reformas sociales que están suscitando
preocupación entre la comunidad lgbt y q
más
podemos ver ahora mismo muchas leyes que
se promueven contra la comunidad lgbtiq
más contra los palestinos contra
minorías más grandes en Israel y estamos
aquí para decir alto y claro que todos
nosotros árabes judíos diferentes
comunidades dentro de Israel exigimos
Paz igualdad y Justicia para todos y que
este es el hogar de todos nosotros y
vamos a luchar por ello
la oposición ha acusado al gobierno de
poner en peligro todo el sistema
jurídico de Israel y afirma que las
últimas reformas tocaban sus
instituciones democráticas